en tenue de combat il s'est rendu
lui-même sur les lieux
ce lundi le chef des séparatistes de
deniers Denis
le centre de barmouth complètement
détruit par la guerre
occasion pour lui de se mettre en scène
dans une vidéo dont la date et le lieu
reste à confirmer l'homme du Kremlin
affirme que son armée contrôle plus de
75% de la ville
voici darkmouth que nous appelons
artiomovsk en train d'être libéré par
les soldats de Wagner
l'ennemi n'épargne pas la ville ni les
siens et les Poussots hachoirs
sanglant entre les armées russes et
ukrainiennes pour Moscou gagner cette
bataille faciliterait de nouvelles
offensives à travers l'Ukraine là où
pour Kiev la ville en ruine n'a plus
qu'une valeur symbolique mais l'armée
ukrainienne ne cesse de se perfectionner
à quelques kilomètres de barmouth ces
soldats continuent de s'entraîner au
milieu d'armes assourdissantes au Lexan
lui en détient une beaucoup plus
discrète sa mission piloter des drones
au-dessus de l'épicentre des combats
résultat il a réussi à découvrir un chat
russe à 2 km de leur position
avant l'utilisation des drones les
calculs étaient faits par des géomètres
l'homme devait se placer en hauteur avec
un trépied des jumelles d'artillerie il
devait regarder puis donner des angles
de correction à l'artilleur et effectuer
des modifications aujourd'hui grâce au
drone l'artilleur peut voir et ajuster
le tir en temps réel sur la cible
ces derniers mois il est trop prus sont
progressés au nord et au sud de marmouth
coupant plusieurs routes
d'approvisionnement ukrainienne depuis
quelques jours elles sont progressées
dans le centre nourrissant à nouveau les
spéculations d'un retrait ukrainien
imminent